this is where the US government got an F
for the pandemic loneliness accelerates
dementia and the biggest threat to a
good old age is not it's it's not good
health it's not running out of money
it's isolation the most important thing
you can have is a solid social we
already feel we're in a loneliness
epidemic one of my favorite things to do
besides making videos of course is to
play football I'm actually quite good
but the reason is that I always feel
happy afterwards it's about the social
connection and as someone who falls in
that border of iner extraer well
actually according to my most recent
test I am an extraer social connections
are important irrespective of your
personality type but how important how
does it impact Your Health and Longevity
and what can we learn from ants the
super social insects that depends on
each other and what changes can be made
to mitigate this loneliness p pandemic
well let's start with what is currently
known about human Health and Social
isolation while I talk frequently about
disease in terms of physical and
functional decline I need to remind
myself of my favorite BBC bite-sized
definition of Health that I was taught
at school which is that Health can be
defined as the complete physical mental
and social well-being and not only the
absence of illness or
infirmity emphasis here on the social
well-being as social wellbe is important
and there are some Landmark human
studies that show it firstly there have
been several reports linking social
isolation with loneliness with high
risks for health problems such as heart
disease depression cognitive decline and
mortality rates in fact one study found
that when multi-dimensional assessments
of social relationships were considered
the odds of mortality increased by 91%
among the socially isolated this
magnitude is comparable to that of
smoking and exceeds those of of many
other known risk factors of mortality
such as obesity and physical
inactivity so social isolation is quite
simply the lack of relationships with
others with little to know social
support or contact loneliness is feeling
alone or disconnected it is feeling like
you don't have meaningful or close
relationships or a sense of belonging
this means that even a person with lots
of friends can still feel
lonely take a look at this other study
by combining data from four large
nationally representative
populationbased studies using an
Innovative longitudinal life course
Design This study provided previously
unidentified causal evidence on the
mechanisms linking social relationship
patterns with Health and Longevity
across the human
lifespan the more socially integrated
had lower blood pressure and C reactive
protein
levels later on in this study they
showed that it's not just about social
integration and the number of friends
but also about the quality of those
relationships
as you can see in these figures it is
looking at systolic blood pressure waist
circumference and body mass index and
comparing those with either low support
or high support friendships or low
strain or high strain relationships at
different age groups one of the most
interesting findings from the study was
that having more strain full
relationships had stronger associations
with an increased body mass index higher
levels of the Ser active protein and a
larger waste circumference than with the
low support relationships in other words
first finding which is the quality of
the relationships trumped quantity far
more in terms of impact on health but
what was really the most interesting
thing in the study was if you have the
choice in the matter between making a
new close supportive friend or getting
rid of that high maintenance friend
who's been like you've needed like a
hole in the head for the last 30 years
the source of strain was more of an
adverse effect on health than source of
support being a good thing on health
suggesting that more more stressful
relationships are even worse for our
health than the lack of having
beneficial
relationships however either way it
showed further evidence that there is
this link between social integration
both in terms of quality and quantity
and our health but it raises the
question as to how does this lead to
this increased risk of death and adverse
Health outcomes well this is when we
have to come back to the carpenter ants
a usocial species of ants and you
sociality is according to Wikipedia
defined as the highest level of
organization of sociality but animals
live in a group show Cooperative care of
juveniles not all individuals reproduce
and they overlap in Generations it is
not just seen in ants but bees termites
are my favorit the naked moats and it's
interesting to note that the evolution
of VI sociality is associated with a
hundredfold increase in insect lifespan
compared to the equivalent species that
are non usocial but while the more
logical explanation here is the fact
that by living Liv in large colonies
they are more sheltered and heavily
defended against predators it is
interesting to observe that when you
socially isolate one of these carpenter
ants they have a decreased lifespan and
so what they did in this very recent
study is they tried to understand what
was causing this decrease in the
lifespan of the ants and what they
observed was that there was an increased
observation of reactive oxygen species
in the ants but not just anywhere in the
ants specifically in the cells that are
like C cells the inite and in the fat
body of the
ants so this provided some evidence that
it was this increased reactive oxygen
species that was potentially driving the
decreased
lifespan now there are certain compounds
that are antioxidants that can help to
reduce or detoxify these reactive oxygen
species such as melatonin and so
intriguingly in this paper they then did
the experiment where they gave socially
isolated ants melatonin and it actually
reduced some of the drop in lifespan
caused by the
isolation importantly there was no
change in lifespan when melatonin was
given to ants that remained within the
social group now while I could
potentially make some interesting point
that melatonin is commonly taken to Aid
with sleep loss and other Studies have
shown that socialization in dropil the
fruit flies causes sleep deprivation
however it is thought that melatonin
doesn't have an involvement in this
Cadian rhythm in these ants and moreover
it is unlikely that this would be an
effective solution for loneliness in
humans so how do we decrease this
incidence of
loneliness well the reason I made this
video wasn't to come across this
negative because loneliness affects all
of us albeit not all of the time
necessarily but we all feel it instead I
wanted to highlight that this is
something that is potentially more
easily inable and could have large
benefits to our health and interestingly
this Ted Talk I recommend speaks exactly
on this topic how to find F the
loneliness
pandemic one of her recommendations is
this of course combating loneliness
involves more than just forming new
connections it also requires deepening
our existing connections with our
colleagues friends and loved
ones to establish a deeper connection
with someone um you have to openly
exchange your mental contents with each
other talk about your thoughts feelings
beliefs and desires
we scientists call this process a
conversation but in general I hope that
this video makes it apparent that there
are simple ways that by improving social
relationships it has benefits for health
I'm fortunate that I'm s a university
where I can easily take part in team
sports but soon this might not be the
case and I like the quote from this
article where it explains that we need
to fundamentally rethink how societies
can look beyond the medical causes of
disease in an effort to promote health
and wellbeing and that governments can
and should do much toward this goal even
during a period of economic crisis so I
will steal the ending from this Ted Talk
which is instead of saying thank you for
listening I will instead say
[Music]
hello